yeah man so was so full chili da we're
here with the echoing [ __ ] man we just
saw I'm Dean Edwards oh yeah in or Smith
and uh they're rich and rich rich who um
who's in a lot of commercials right now
on buffalo wings no jack-in-the-box we
have a sponsor today how are you gonna
do it with you oh it's an online betting
company based in Venice Beach called
parachute
they make sheets duvet comforters and
other bedding essentials their bathing
is made of 100% long staple Egyptian
cotton so you could be an arabian night
[ __ ] manufactured in a Mayo in
Tuscany that's been weaving bedding for
nearly 80 years and then shipped to your
door
Tuscany man so you know I mean it must
be good because hath tusks on it
parachute cuts out the licensing and
distribution fees so you can experience
high quality bedding for less so there
you have a people barrier chute cuts off
the middleman if you have quality
parachute also gives back in a big way
they partnered with the United Nations
Foundation nothing but nets campaign to
deliver life-saving malaria prevention
bed nets to those in need go to
parachute home comm /foo use promo code
full that's fo o L and parachute will
give you $25 off on your first order
actually people we got some of those
sheets the other day and I was picked
you don't know another ship only two
came actually know people I do have our
men they're very comfortable I feel warm
but I also feel that there's nothing
covering me up but it's like you know I
do I like the feeling you know they
don't slide off you know we got we got
the sheets a month ago they're very
comfortable
I like their website they have a lot of
cool tips on designing your bedroom tips
on getting a good night's sleep
and I even learned how to fold a fitted
sheet on their site
there was one strange thing there what
you're right there was no top sheet I
thought was missing at first but then I
realized it wasn't part of the package
and I look at that looked at the site
they do this for a reason I saw a study
on their site that showed that 40% of
Americans sleep without a cop sheet and
you know what Isaac my son is one of
them and the reason is he hates how it
bunches up and tangles up in his legs
and the Venice bidding betting didn't
come with a top sheet and I thought I'd
miss it but we've had the sheets for you
know a couple weeks now and I don't miss
it what do you think I don't miss it
either you know but you know I grew up
you know my mom liked Rodrigo and grew
up you know how many blanket did your
mom put on top of you growing up seven
seven huh I mean my mom will put like a
[ __ ] salmon out the white sheet then
she put a regular cover and then three
San Marco blankets because man your mom
did I want you to get out of that bed of
wrap like a burrito
okay people remember go to parachute
home calm /foo use promo code fool
that's f o o L and parachute will give
you $25 off on your first order so
what's up for how's your weekend don't
[ __ ] know you know just [ __ ] ended
kind of week with the radar loss on
Sunday I know we had a week our foe I
drove bromine Tripathi we drove to UM
road trip road trip we ended up spending
the night in um we're at we spent the
night in Santa Barbara because you guys
have like a bed and breakfast you guys
go to write or some [ __ ] like that
yeah we go to Morro Bay bro Morro Bay is
this playable they have a big rock and
now I think they film the movie the
birds there the birds which is uh Alfred
Hitchcock yeah so it's a good place to
go man if you were like bird-watching
and there's a big volcano rock in the
middle of the ocean and a lot of birds
hangouts in the right hand side there's
some hardcore waves like mad ones mad
ones yeah what'd you guys do the scenic
route over there the 101 the scenic
route 101 it was tight you went to the
stadium though - alright go to the
stadium man
yeah well you know we have anybody in
this town
does the Latin descent is Lakers I go
yeah oh okay you cool that's all I have
to say we put night makers L a-kor yes
you ask anybody bro why they call the
Lakers bro nah bro cool you know Echo
Park Lake Michigan they've always been
for me later know what's happening man
we're so mad fellow vegan and we're my
church yeah you know and I'm look at
your body it is dis disss looking like a
thinking warrior man I'm getting there
bro I'm getting like a SJ warrior bro
but I'm more like a a state warrior that
the one they post up on top of the basic
and bakery
oh yeah well I loved your show oh thank
you for being I really think thought you
were I still do think you're hilarious
I did a podcast with which a girl who
opens for you
Felicia Michaels Marcela and Marcela
well yes she's Hall Wow
she was like almost looking me eye to
eye bro and I kept thinking I'm looking
at it and I know her fingers as long as
my fingers man she might be built like
me to this if we had a kid man it would
speak Spanish and Ebonics and it would
be about nine foot tall how much money
we would get on that kid oh my god I
thought about it anyway doctor winning
outside the door Dolby Aging's
commercial deals the rock one day is
gonna be like that man you're gonna
genetically what happened here all right
must be the air sometime one day they're
gonna genetically make some valuable
yeah I'm watching this show right now
called orphan black I love you my
chicken is ready people get it you hear
when you hear that noise during a live
podcast that means some hot chick gotta
like so so Rodrigo man chilling down but
you have problem with the ladies John
man really I'm serious man this guy
would like a girls photos are they -
they block him does that has more blocks
than than the rodman so wait do you
really online date no no I would on a
date on a Friday night but it was all it
was all of that eve Doug's in harmony
you hook up with Chamber Raider jackets
and their profile
I'm not wholly nothing bag
no libras ed if you want to date me I
have a triple legs jacket waiting for
you I literally saw this thing man
like somebody was talking about tinder
and I had never seen it there's no
reason for me to see tinder and then I
saw tinder and I could not believe that
some of these people on tinder are
really on tinder like it's like they
don't care I know man they have him
subway he was on kinder picks him up and
drops them off I don't know man I know I
don't know I just know I can't even see
the fences I can't even do on snapchat I
don't understand snapchat you know I was
just to get to the basics right now I
made my space man Jane later if you
don't pass this on you're gonna break
the chains without crumbled-up scroll
anyway so do you date yeah okay what's
that mean like what's that mean you went
on a date Friday does that mean you
didn't go on a date Saturday
no okay did you have the ability to go
on a date Saturday yeah is it a date or
is it a it is it a hookup a date
now what happens on a date it's got to
eat chill talk then what chilled talk
and then you know go back to the car
hang out make out bail out make out yeah
that's a hand and an mouth kissing yeah
then both go to their separate homes
yeah
and I say like I had a hookup you know
the week before I'm like over that [ __ ]
really only hookers you get a month yeah
when I [ __ ] this one was just the first
one of that month but I just saying so
[ __ ] empty like I'm on the [ __ ]
doc really yeah don't jerk off before
your day bro I didn't fool she was
loaded dog locked and [ __ ] that's crazy
that you were never have that has not
happened to me in probably 15 years just
walk and then we go our separate ways
I like this take that happened before
ago and ruin our separate ways and I
call up my ex-girlfriend we hooked up
that night yeah your wife is happy you
just said that 100 I guess what she's
been waiting for thank you I did with
our separate ways and they drove home I
never had a date then then of course you
like her and I haven't been dating
lately either but you know of course you
would you said that yeah because I'm
trying I'm trying to do this
relationship show it's not just about
you know boys and girls it's like
relationship with your with your with
your job relationship with your coworker
with your family you know the
relationship between your father your
mother that's what I want to do so but I
I always go back to this with men you
didn't have sex with her because you
liked her but if you have sex with
surmise because you don't like them no
like I've been with chicks where I had
sex with and I don't even like them
after that after that yeah and then this
one I mean I didn't get to that point
you don't realize you didn't like him
before the sex I can't have more like
lust it's like do you didn't like him
you never liked them yeah I like what
this chick had to say everything her
personality all that [ __ ] what she was
wearing what she was into Howard is my
age 37 how many times she'd been married
once how long I don't know how long but
I'm she has a child
how old five
she's Mexican yeah she remarried for
five years
man are you telling me 37 years old so
what do you think you're gonna do it 40
I don't know though hopefully be alive I
mean not like you know I got it all
prepped out in my career but that time
it should be here should be there
financially economically not want to
live work and you know be a little free
and [ __ ] yeah you've been a fruit for a
while huh huh 37 years oh damn
37 how do you know I'm 47 man you're 47
yeah you seriously don't look like you
and your forties I know man
Cammi you don't look like your and your
work man I think I don't worry about
nothing really yeah man
now I have kids and they've grown up now
and yeah just because your stage acts
seems like you go yeah major you have
let it go just let it go man let go and
let it happen you like this now or you
die oh did you never give a [ __ ] or well
I do give a [ __ ] man but you know just
that um I don't know why I just nobody
my family loves that old like my dad's
word up he was born in I don't even know
his age but he's old jeans but he's like
the Playboy at his gruff is dying every
month I know man
my dad we take it as Gophers - bingo
bowling casinos he's right there
spinning the good weight to give here
like yeah I was like yes this is the
date man this is date so what's up fools
- nothing only the first date I don't
know I don't think you just know just
often right dude like there's [ __ ]
chicks to hit me up and [ __ ] but I won't
[ __ ] I have time up yeah why I'm a
track I have to be attractive to a chick
I like
[ __ ] dog but it's like oh yeah do like
in [ __ ] in a towards the Tucson or
after that New Mexico show do this big I
mean it's not even the fact of what she
look like she would leave me alone and
[ __ ] and I finally had to tell her world
but back home I got a girlfriend oh you
have a girlfriend
and then this fool and [ __ ] Pete
Munoz are you really who what's-her-name
[ __ ] up and tell him something [ __ ] get
her off me dog I don't know that I was
like wait what does she look like
yeah she look like a truck okay well
y'all having a conversation ah dude
[ __ ] somebody let her in the [ __ ]
back room to take a piss dog and she
wouldn't [ __ ] leave dog yeah and it's
like it's not leave the green room in
the back and then [ __ ] they had some
friends I had some weed so [ __ ]
started puffing [ __ ] lingers and then
[ __ ] you know been a big asset dude
on my own going through [ __ ] like who
the [ __ ] I mean I would never go to the
backstage room and start picking that
[ __ ] I just like I'm just happy I'm
there cool whatever
[ __ ] let me know when you need me
leave these people [ __ ] started
kicking their [ __ ] shoes off turn on
the TV and [ __ ] I was like [ __ ] yeah but
then you know other people you know hit
me or the one who hit you up on
Instagram tool like after she added me a
so what's up you're so nice yes I do and
then did you not just say yo who you
with nah
this is all yeah who's this guy doing
but I think that it's gonna be like keep
on [ __ ] nagging at me like trying to
scrape at my ass now I'm good on that
[ __ ] man well I do the inverse is like
fools try to hook me up with you I was
thinking about this other day cuz I've
been on tour with the band since I was
15 and I was like 18 we're on tour and
this fool brings two chicks on hey what
up dude they're here to [ __ ] hook up
with you I might now for I gotta go to
sleep cuz we're gonna go to corporates
next day I'm gonna walk around and check
out the scenery and they're just
tripping out I'm gonna go what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this [ __ ] yeah but
I mean I wasn't really attracted those
chicks either dog they were just kind of
little dumpy oh my [ __ ] all that to me
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] to other fools maybe
but you know I mean whatever mmm
hmm sorry you guys had to hear that yeah
but that's how you know creak yeah it
was great
you've got the guys say bra iverson
practice and they said and he said you
know all the skin around the vagina is
called woman so if you thinking about
anything outside of that hole I wonder
why you thinking like is like panties
and bra match I had a guy later this day
who cares if I'm panties and bra fit see
coming out of home like you know who
cares what car she drove what kind of
shoes you got on is he is he [ __ ] or
not they came up to me what tell if I
hop in Lakewood all bad this is [ __ ]
cute this cute chick over there man she
was just she wants to know your name at
Bushehr some big-ass dog thumbs own just
saw her double even that baby was around
you know I wanted to be over there but
it was in the tow family it was a
mistletoe we just turned me off she was
cute but you got those thumbs first term
could have been pressing the butter like
nuts they did a woman who just came out
of prison who did he will rebound me
Rodrigo a girl just came out of doing 10
years 3 she was hot dog yeah man three
years man yeah he got that origin
new black [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy I saw a
friend of mine on Facebook who did like
I think she did like eight years of a
12-year sentence and and she just got
married I saw that on Facebook smiling
I was like man you're like she can just
keep going like it's like nobody to the
neighborhood knows dad this chick was
slinging crack pop it down the west
coast
now she's smiling and good PTA got a
felon in the coal to say yeah it's just
like weeds
I'm telling us if they have no idea soon
as she starts making that prison spread
something they start wondering ha ha
this girl makes a lot of casserole oh my
god she may take like hot cheetos just
go just wait a high fee cake I made this
came with Oreos 7up and peanut butter it
is vegan dope now on is begin mmm but
not healthy now he'll know on how do we
make it like half a box of Oreos and you
take out all the other white feeling out
first and you crunch it all up in a
casserole then you pour like a coca-cola
in it and let it simmer in the microwave
the whole thing
microwave yeah and then it gets it to
that this big Oreo cake and then when
the leftover cream filling you mix that
up with um with some a cup of peanut
butter so now you got frosting and
peanut butter and you put that over the
cake I started on YouTube yeah this big
buff dude was cooking it in prison don't
eat it all those things you mentioned
should not be ingested no human body to
myself man I could just lose I know
older than I am I might lose my back
party tooth on that meal
you would lose anything
hey just the other day I bought a
coca-cola in the bottle cuz I hadn't
seen in a bottle in so long and I just
had it cuz I always liked the way it
looked and I said I haven't had a
coconut I'm it it tastes the same but it
does different things in my body now
than it did when I was younger like I
had to go lay down for a couple hours
like seriously okay poisoned you yeah I
just I don't know if it poisoned me but
it literally my body had said shut down
till we figure out what you just did to
yourself and since then I've been okay I
can't have any more cola
it wasn't coca-cola it was Cola was that
a Mexican Coke yeah it was some brand
that just said Cola on it and I think
that's where I got caught up I was like
oh it's in a bottle and it just says
Cola as I haven't seen that in forever
so you know my brain is thinking oh this
is the old style man I was and it wasn't
it was a wait I get I got it downtown so
trust me they sell them poison
I feel the same way too about the sports
drinks there have to be one sports drink
or energy drink that gave me any energy
no I just give me this high kick taken
ah it's like I want to put on a karate
suit and take a nap instead you know I
got something for you too I uh this you
have you heard of thrive market no
Balaji go said in the episode he wanted
to lose weight and try and try I'm gonna
I'm gonna give you this cuz everybody
listen to you I'm gonna give you these
uh these membership card I'll do it for
free so we can give it out to people so
they can get all healthy and vegan foods
good man cuz I just joined the YMCA in
Glendale young have you been to any
Glendale right early in the morning it's
like you're your man it's like the cast
of the Titanic is naked I mean man I
mean the guy man
I feel like I'm in a concentration camp
with black hair everybody swimming pool
not swimming just loading bootleg happy
to be alive and then like you gotta take
a shower before you go to the pool but
me I just you know I'm I just wet myself
like I do a public public pool I just
wet myself in love with my hair lose
weight and his old Russian guy told me
to tie to a ratted me out so now I go
hey he didn't take no shower but you
know for dinner but see man the front of
my body is wet so that life good looking
at me the foot of our bodies are wet he
just took a shower his whole body wet
but the back is all dry the back is all
try this fool ready we are twice twice
the lifeguard told him no sir he took a
shower I could see took a shower why is
he watching if you take a shower the old
man this is better to do man this is
patrol right there yeah YMCA president
okay so why would you not want to take
us I didn't take a shower man you know
I'm wondering myself no my beak
I can't just fool slipping at Ralph's
supermarket dog oh you bump this car and
I always card take a shower lose my
memory bro I'm away for a while to make
more money make a big donation then
nobody can [ __ ] with me that's how you
do it bro oh yeah I put the bricks in
that wall I pay for the plumbing I mess
was that bad man
so what I do now I want hopefully I make
a bit of what I want to do is just
become his friend and then invited to
play basketball and then they help make
have a heart attack bro running around
or something you know I have it all
planned out of my head so we gotta get
you out some better beautiful maybe some
raw food I will drown this fool so in my
head I'm swimming you know doing my last
planning his death you know okay how I
get this old man okay I'll do it
he's coming I know that he goes into the
steam room right after he swims so I'll
just lather up the whole floor with soap
and he walks in there Pera he slips this
is wonderful career you still want too
much Godfather the new OJ Simpson ervice
out here in California it's funny too
people go oh man I hated you in your
piston I go I don't know how to answer
that I'm like okay yeah man but you made
up for when you became a Laker I said
okay they go who's your favorite team
whichever one paid first
paid on time I I played in the NBA I
don't really care about the team's plus
I'm not a fan so I don't know like all
the guys playing not like I like LeBron
I like him and I like Steph Curry I like
I love Harden out of Houston and Durant
and Westbrook and of course Kobe's my
favorite I got punched in the stomach by
like so check this out I'm my Kentucky
Derby and I and Chris Tucker and Dave
Chappelle I've always say anything but I
thought Kobe was better than Mike at
this time you know what I thought like
stupid stuff and people would ask me so
Michael Jordan sitting there and they've
run up they go right here right here in
front of your boy right now
Kobe and Michael which one now standing
over here is Charles Oakley and I saw
the bodyguard and I don't really you
know I'm sitting out over the city cat
and I go what do you mean at what age
they said right now that Kobe was 27 and
I looked at Michael I said 27 or 27
young fella would give you two business
and Oakley comes over and punched me
straight in the stomach and that's all
the air out of me and I go down but I I
see him at the last moment and they're
playing it you know I'm trying to play
it off like I'm laughing I can't breathe
like Mike who got to grab me said you
know sounds crazy I think I still have
part of my rib is missing from saying
that so I am definitely a Kobe fan and I
got punched in the stomach but literally
telling the great one that I thought at
27 if you had cobia 27 and Michael at 27
Kobe be better that's what I said so I
am a Laker fan since we're out here in
California yeah man man there's that and
um I'm a dumb friends that told me they
have friends that name their kid Kobe
really yeah Kobe Lopez Kobe Lopez I know
the name is kid Kobe yeah man because of
the basketball yeah without the mini
Kareem name magazine named Karim's nah
no no no Cudi mios all he has to do with
homeboy marry new mexican chick tuna
what's up with what people who look at
your goal I don't know you put it for
the Pistons I thought you were Laker the
whole time um yeah I run across a lot of
folk who don't know and it's funny man
when they start talking about my crack I
retired like 15 years ago
so I played in 80s and the 90s so I when
they even talk about man I used to watch
you play a guy how old you and they say
Oh 27 yeah I say watch you play with
David Aguirre
no AG wire Mark McGwire mark Aguirre
wire and I always saying they mark are
giving I knew that his dad or somebody
family Mexican right mm-hmm
yeah so what so I remember I busted a
tweet one time and I said that um I said
Mark McGwire more masculine Mencia
and then people say shut up
do you guys still go after men scene nom
nom yeah they used to go out of man Wow
that's like a MC battle when all the
Spanish guys didn't like him I like what
the hell is happening here well he
didn't hire enough people were having
with you I don't know he didn't do this
to me they say he stole a lot of
people's jobs but I was very offended
because he never stole my jobs at the
time but I knew - right
no was it yeah cuz when I did my pilot
here
he was my comedian and and I know he did
I gave him let him do a set it was a
pilot for this for my late-night talk
show and and then I just did a show a
little while ago called game on and in
they did it and I'm in I saw him go
through the roof and then some disappear
and then come back to it it's kind of
hard to be funny all the time especially
when you got kids I know man
yeah because then you guys start
thinking they might hear this one day
they might figure out I don't like them
as much as I say yeah or your kids will
tell you yeah take care of your other
family other family like that was joke
about stable I'm here with my other
family just joke doc there's a cable
guys nothing there was a cable guy like
what you did ain't that comedian bro
Steve Rannazzisi disease the smokes
cleared how I'm gonna be going after
that full of nasty style hot for line I
don't even know that I'd even know that
was true I didn't know nothing about I
just knew that he was a calf in a Comedy
Store and neither did I do till right
now started like looking up the hash tag
Steve Rannazzisi ins now he admitted he
lied and that homeboy from SNL tweeting
him back on that shake his dad really
died in that you really yeah guess he's
lying about that he survived September
11th and snuck up the
building before collapsed I gotta admit
that by the way people did not start a
Leroy their job is near the riot like I
said man I was looting my mom's purse
all the time
she didn't even go outside I started
knocking over kitchen appliances in my
own house starting a fire outside and I
was never involved nollie riots I just
wonder why people what would make him
think that that like what would make him
think his career was gonna last on the
line well I don't know man
I think at the moment - he's like man
it's this mad glorious [ __ ] I can say
real quick get on the map people love me
but it's probably like when once he
started doing it social media wasn't
that crazy now you can say shouldn't
boom in a [ __ ] second they'll figure
your ass out oh you can make it up yep
and then it'll be real yawns and like
it's crazy like fake is the new real so
you can make it up cuz I saw somebody I
don't know how long reality shows are
gonna last so everybody knows that
they're if you watch just The Biggest
Loser you know that somebody's gonna cry
and they're gonna tell you something
about their parents why they're fat
right this is why it has nothing to do
with me has nothing to do with self
control has nothing to do with the fact
that I haven't been eating food ever has
nothing to do that I don't drink water
nothing nothing none of that [ __ ] it has
to do with my jeans I inherit it that's
what happened and then they showed him
working out when they shouldn't and they
lose weight and they celebrate right
people know this is a setup
if the cameras there why would you wait
to the cameras there to tell me some
personal you know family [ __ ] so people
are gonna realize there's a so I think
you better go back to acting class cause
pretty soon actors are gonna start
getting paid again that's what I think
I don't know I just thought it a [ __ ]
show that's what my friends are trying
to get on Last Comic Standing I was on
Last Comic Standing and I won and I
don't know what should I say bow it's
anybody and always ask them is there
anybody in your family right now dying
of anything your mom missing a limb any
of your ground Paris was OB enough--but
none so you had a simple like being in a
wind shape you know you're gonna be the
bad guy of the show yeah I know
adversity you know I know you're a nice
guy in real life or doing a painting of
the [ __ ] my daughter's going on
American Idol like she's on the last
show and on the last you know before it
goes away and Sochi we're going over all
these songs she wants a thing and then
I'm picking out these songs and she's
seeing names and she's like why just
skip over to Whitney Houston song or I
just skip over to Sarah Vaughn so why
just skip over to wreath or Franklin but
but no I cuz I don't want you to start
off on the wrong foot that's like saying
I'm gonna be the quarterback on a
patriot I know Brady was good for 15
years and he's you know the man but I'm
gonna step in and don't do that you want
to go to a team that doesn't you know
let's start off slow so I'm looking at
all these songs man I forgot how many
great songs and I said to her I said
they're gonna start asking you questions
about me and she's a Panamanian write a
mother from Panama but I I raised her so
she was that they want to know why did
you take me from my mom oh oh no I said
I had a better house I had a better
house I didn't want you to be raised in
Brooklyn and so your mom agreed that you
should come live in the better house she
had to stay in Brooklyn with her mother
and her grandmother mmm
I was like Gigi don't let him in my life
she was like I got to do it I got to
come up with something like they are
already like he said they're already
like did your dad punch you to hit like
something to give her to make people cry
for a second
it has to be that way yeah that sucks
I think people gonna know some of my
business yeah and you don't sleep at
night it was upside down 300 years old
shits about to come out
can't put butter my greens
you start to realize man like Oh like
places like like the most hardest place
for a vegan to eat it's probably Cracker
Barrel oh no question cuz everything has
butter hell yeah I did I didn't know -
we went that day that before they would
start to make the pancakes they put like
a OH a cup of butter first on the pan
then it for the pancakes then you had
more butter on your pancakes then run
with your sausage and that's just a
breakfast what's the most food you've
eaten when you were not a vegan you said
down I picked out oh I was I would go to
this place called beautiful restaurant
in Atlanta and then it was run by like I
guess they look like Christians but they
I guess they were I don't know what he's
it would be open late at night and they
had everything and a dead animal you
know I mean there's like in the hood
like almost like a fish fry type thing
with it you smell them always cooking
something in a barrel and uh so he would
go into this and they would have two
grits and the eggs and and the bacon and
the sausage and the ribs like take this
out you have breakfast and you know how
you you dip your own [ __ ] you know black
folks love going to a buffet and this I
would have ribs so people for breakfast
after the club five o'clock in the
morning eggs grits
and a slab of ribs and then like after
they'd be after they finished eating
it's seven o'clock is they've been there
for our just sitting still so I think
that's when when I was putting flesh in
my body dead animal flesh in my body I
think that's when I yeah yeah I felt I
felt bad for like a week at least at
least a week and I used to see this all
the time so I was always wonder why I
fell shitty I was smiling and giggling
but I I'm smiling giggling but I had
like a quick temper I know why then I
started eating better you chew out when
they actually love pork chops but after
a pork chop
I've never went for a walk I will pass
out yeah I'm never like oh I slowly tell
people not to give me a pork chop no
more the peas will give you pork chops
and then I would my Mogi report
traveling this fall asleep I fall asleep
like run away man
Wow you know that's clusters parasites
and pork and it goes to your brain
I just got into this whole parasite you
know I help people get healthy
this whole parasite thing dr. arse
talked about it and some other people I
said to me let me get back in this was
huge in was like almost everywhere like
that little work I did as soon as we got
rid of the pimple some to get rid of the
parasite they started gonna last I said
eat a lot of punk she goes every day
I like wow this knowing that it really
is that works
I don't break out anymore so they've
been vegan daughter you see that I
notice now before I'll get a pump employ
every once in a while you know in my
groin area you know but not anymore
you mean a boy you ain't grown here yeah
so you became vegan ninety-one no man I
became a vetted a lion vegetarian
Alliance to agree of cheese yeah I would
even fish in Turkey and shrimp and as I
anything a red meat well you still in
chicken when it was around I'm not
eating any red meat I'm a vegetarian and
much cheese as possible but you know
nevertheless I got behave when I was
doing that yeah I had to get her out and
so eight years ago I became a vegan I
started eating raw about um September
first see a raw vegan now yeah so I eat
raw most of the day and then I like a
vegan meal one vegan meal a day you hear
that people who think they all flee but
you're a vegan [ __ ] but man be raw
vegan is even harder yeah that mean you
can eat Oreos right or notor butters
mm-hmm and is it I went got these uh Tom
at the farmers market this guy got this
thing I don't give their name I think
healthy whatever and it's a jar it's a
superfood it looks like a peanut butter
right it's hemp seed hemp seed berries
and all this that was like eighteen
dollars for this thing and I was like
dude he goes hey man this is this is
real food I'm like I I got an $18 one
team down yeah it better be like man I
put this on so and I I ate it the way he
said I haven't eaten anything else this
fun like I'm full like my stomach is
saying don't throw any yeah so I like it
I kind of kind of dig it because I don't
have to spend a lot of time eating
things I don't have to be there for long
period of time when you eat raw you eat
when you're hungry that's the problem
about jiggle being being a man he likes
chewing
which is good for your food that's
chewing man you can see like if you had
a quick meal like he just said just a
couple of chewy you're done you'll be
like what the [ __ ] the first course
right don't let your data when you gonna
try it raw yeah I don't know man I've
tried it a couple times really and you
know the whole thing is you know being a
vegan and stuff is hard you have to
really discipline yourself to make stuff
I mean everybody that you hang out with
eats meat and [ __ ] this is only fool I
know that does that and in her everybody
else's uni was like I don't know you a
vegetarian when you're in the Pistons
yeah
and hanging out with those guys but
those guys were but you have these
steaks and lobster every night
steakhouse I was at steak house
two weeks ago in Phoenix there was a
Dominic's the same people who start at
Mastro's and larry fitzgerald football
player had his um his foundation dinner
and so I hosted it but you know when
they were feeding everybody I said uh
I'm not coming down there and they
bought me upstairs and they made me a
cauliflower steak and I know I've never
heard of it either until I got there
this Dave this dude made when he heard I
was coming made the best food in the
steakhouse he said he's all organic
he said cuz I made them buy organic
because I serve organic vegetables he
said I said they they took whatever that
thing is they cleaned off the grid off
the griddle he said I you have this own
section he knew everything about being a
vegan and he made it he's and I saw you
said you don't like butter you only like
coconut oil
not even that the fake butter you like
coconut oil you said so this is all made
with coconut oil
it was the most food and the best
tasting ever so I would I would agree
with you until you tell the chef that
you're a vegan cuz moshe member you go
to when you if you're a chef that's all
I got to say it that way you've been to
least say from
you've been to call down blue or
something you've been certified as a
chef there's a difference right you get
rated that way I mean any other way your
cook so as a chef they teach them how to
cut meat and they tell them how to what
to do with temperature and how to season
but then for 45 to 60 minutes they
they're not doing anything that's not
cook that's baking right so they have to
learn how to do things with vegetables
they have to learn how to make things
taste and move and function so it's it's
a challenge tool so just going whisper
to the waiter hey I'm a vegan and if the
chef can impress me with some vegan food
make sure I tell them no butter and low
on olive oil man you come you had a best
food in the world and you know what if
anything happened you can always just
walk into a grocery store and grab a
whole bunch of vegetables $12 and just
chew on them like it's gonna have to be
that way because if I say the other way
we didn't think about this think about
this how much better you feel maybe I
said well you got to die some way they
tell me that all the time I go right but
I don't have to feel bad now
like I'm gonna be dead soon so I might
as well feel good as much as I possibly
can you feel better when you die so you
should try it I tried that one time at
Cracker Barrel I took a guy I'm vegan
what do you got got
well I could cut up some fruit for you
so the guy went to go cut up his furrows
the way to clear it up himself he told
me they buy it all back and that I was
tasting the Apple the pineapple
everything I tasted they to the onion so
he could use the knife he bought a knife
from the cook that was [ __ ] cutting
onions all day they could have my fruit
I was a child him you know may know
these [ __ ] vegetables these
like onion but I know his answer would
have been well you know onions begin
right nothing was ever to play on the
margins I I put lemon inside whatever
hate it cuz it'll bunions I didn't do
that [ __ ] they cut him up for you
because there was nothing else I didn't
get you that was on the menu that could
Bank Wow
so you know what that's that's a trip
you know I should you got all these
cities I said I should hook you up with
all the top vegan restaurants there when
you get there to bring you food that'll
be cool that'll be cool man you waiting
right there so what for my dinner
Birdman's there before me needs it
something like when I go out yeah he's
gonna have a vegan you want his bleep
knees like something being into it and
you show up and just like just like this
big ugly best to both vegetable or
platter
yeah with ranch in the middle then I
just eat the vegetable by themselves
yeah or sometimes like one time we had a
vegan now plate and there was no vegan
plate huh
at staple center huh what was it again
boiled chicken broccoli with butter yeah
yeah peanut butter jelly sandwich we
can't find anything else yeah so I had a
I just did for PETA
this year the 10 the 10 top arenas would
vegan options and the best is like
Dallas that is when the Cobb was played
yeah they make some from Connor being in
caviar joint they laid it out I don't
know how to even know to do that and
there's a really good vegan restaurant
in Dallas nothing it's not the health
you know the vegan food just our bed was
diner yeah yeah one thing we went there
yes I rode I know that's what it is it
was you're a [ __ ] to a place in Houston
called sunshine caffeine yeah at the
Asian dude no no it's always a it's a
black family I think oh no I went to
this Asian dude
yeah don't you know I went to uh that
was a happy cow at net and they sent all
of it and that's how I found this others
way there was Asian God who was in
charge of in Houston but the best one of
the best place I've been to was him well
watch what I say I say but see Otto had
plum but the best pizza entertained food
I had was in Portland yeah it was yeah
this was Portofino so that's what I was
gonna do man I was gonna do and yeah I'm
gonna do this show me going all these
cities I'm going to but we do a piece on
the vegan restaurant but I couldn't get
any sponsors this is no sponsors you
know no one's gonna be able to pay for
that and then they're not gonna put it
on the travel they're not gonna put on a
Travel Channel I gotta put on a Food
Channel because all the commercials or
KFC you'll be on fuse with just any just
hard to get them all to talk to again
I'm trying to get to it so you mean we
can't promote it with milk at leas mm-hm
yeah people say that you're vegan right
you could have you can have yogurt I go
I can have anything I want
but number vegan I choose not to have
anything from an animal's ass and uh
they don't quite get me all the time you
will get asked that a lot of so what can
you eat yeah I see that everything at
Thanksgiving except two dead animals and
all the stuff you put butter on or
somebody I caught you but somebody says
one time it's like in a private people
decide well don't you eat I don't mean
anything they had a mother and a father
mm-hmm yeah I don't swallow anything
mother
yeah come on um people say how about
bees about honey as I eat honey I don't
care about bees how am i captain a
comedian says my captain nobody cares
about bees so we go all the way memory
cookies is honey and bees throw up right
yeah but it has enzymes in it
that can help your digestion it's good
and it kills uh it can help to kill
perfect I footed nice a real Rob boater
bro had three barking and everything had
bees had a beef farmers head and a
finger inside and everything there's a
honey man caught Tupelo Honey that
literally from Mississippi yeah but if
I'm a to his only from this one place
and I don't they don't know why it grows
and these bees along the river and that
honey literally is lower than all the
rest of the honey and so they give it on
the glycemic index and they give it to a
diabetic
what stupid yeah this baby we went to
and now houston we were cool didn't but
maybe was happy cow it was sunshine cafe
and it was all like they had these two
Mexican ladies of course we're getting a
bag of corn and though I mean later the
fact older black lady and everybody well
there was you know remove moving around
they make some girls vegan food though
we had nachos yeah and vegan burritos
well I did yeah I did what city was I am
left Connecticut yeah I went to this
place in Connecticut that was
unbelievable right uh right now ESPN
there's only one spot in and they had to
keep bringing me to this one place it
was only it was like it was like a it
was like a synagogue
it was like one synagogue middle one
town well all the Jews laugh at the
synagogue State that's what it felt like
and so we went in and uh funny they were
black Hebrews to I think what he throws
he bros and uh it made some great food
there too
and you should do that man maybe you
should film everytime every city you go
yeah sometimes I put up a reduction
sometimes I'll put up the food I eat and
you should see all the hate
cuz pose don't know dog I said I mean we
got Mexican bro and he's more pork who
don't know it like the vegan shits like
on point you're like I remember shitty
eating vegan stuff like 20 years ago and
she hadn't that
it tastes as good as the stuff that
tastes now dude it was it was styrofoam
and barbecue so everybody's programmed
with all the [ __ ] that we've been eating
for the last thirty years anyway but you
know Mexicans mainly vegetarians they
didn't really eat a lot of pork the
delicacy it was eating at a pork ear and
when they killed a pork they killed a
pig or hog it went through the whole
village so they didn't kill a lot of
them and they didn't eat a lot of
chicken and if they did it did it almost
like like Mexican food is sushi all
right so what they do at a burrito is
the same thing they would cut up pieces
roll it up and then cut it and then it
looks like that's what it looks like it
looks like sushi so the same mentality
that they were using in Asia but
spreading out the food but they didn't
put up they mostly didn't have a lot of
animal products and it meant meant you
had a lot of money if you can eat
animals in China is the same way too
much stuff too much information I know
man in my house growing up I don't do we
a meat every day
j8 lega beans rice yeah a lot of be the
rights a lot of mm-hmm
yeah that's that's the way it's just you
should go back to that at that dark
those dark beans all those different
kind of beans and other rice but I'm
almost but that means I gotta be in the
kitchen all day oh god ah was it some
chauvinistic but uh Wow that is right
they did you just got the rice I just I
just gave my daughter some uh some vegan
pie yeah and she was I said you liked it
she was like no like this is decima she
means don't bring it again I was like
what was it because I didn't like it
what didn't you like wasn't spicy enough
you should have put some beyond me then
and I was like well I didn't want I want
to just just to be vegetables you were
like it was wack don't make it again
like give me something better than that
make it with I
literally had well I make it with rice I
had all these different vegetables I had
zucchini in it which she thinks I'm
killing her with zucchini I had red
peppers green peppers I use I used clove
I used some hot sauce I used to hot
pepper it was good and she was like you
should have had it like for some cheese
I said it would have changed the whole
thing that would have made it like her
risotto I don't want a risotto I won it
by yeah and she was like I didn't like
it don't do it again so I probably make
it again tomorrow try another you'll
grab somebody else's
wow man sound good yeah I know kid like
we were 11 you at home hating they were
stuffing he was broccoli too
yeah I had to stop bringing broccoli I
can get away with broccolini you know
you getting here to Trader Joe's you can
give rock aleni
but that's it like if she's see
consonance goes up house smells like
somebody was farting I'm not eating that
tonight like that's the worst thing
about making it I even try I tried every
different thing with cauliflower I can't
can't think of another but I like that
see when you talk about cooking I like
that I like sitting back because then I
don't have to think about [ __ ] else but
cooking if I could get away almost like
playing golf it just might hurting
myself when you wait that that
cauliflowers day other tastes it had it
had this uh you know that choco taste
that meet you Stan
yeah that would burn in yeah that's
exactly my boy that's what was taken on
so I guess he cooked it you know you
know in a wood oven or like a pizza oven
type thing and he pressed it somehow but
he wouldn't tell me and he made his own
pesto he was like this dude I I said I
said I'm I do not want to send people to
your restaurant because it's a it's a
place of over but if you in Scottsdale
you've got to go to Dominic's and you
say I want the food Sally had and that's
anybody out there
say I want the vegan option and I don't
want to be around the steak eaters and
he will hook you up because he kept
telling them he said I told this guy man
we should we should have this side and a
vegans honest that's all I can ask for
this time the next hundred years when
I'm 400 years old by that time
everything cauliflower ceviche right
yeah good tasty and it could have been
you know better but it was good you know
but you know you guys you know say [ __ ]
yeah this is good thank you but I'm not
lying to them but I mean could add some
more [ __ ] to it I'm waiting for the
first purses we'll post up a vegan
tailgating do we know who we didn't beat
up I'm sure there's some people don't
you don't people got to talk and
communicate and see who's [ __ ] a beer
broad there's no if there's no medium
beer bro I'm vegan there was some fat
fool sitting behind me bro no but real
fast real fat like like there was a guy
eating peanuts behind me and I didn't go
take a photo with somebody I came back
hit his beer and his peanut crumbs on my
seat and I said there's a beer a penis
on my seat he was too [ __ ] up to clean
it bro his wife had you cleared for him
but I was already on kill mode right
thank you I know that you were leaning
behind me and I say man if I stand up
heart as if I stand up real fast real
fast I go [ __ ] this guy up with a top of
my head knock him out it's an accident
more sticking above him hello planet to
America by the fourth quarter i'ma knock
your mouth he's like I'm just talking
friends your friend passed out II know
what our little shoves you know one of
those old school security show
like talk to you for a minute man and I
went the last Raider game I went to was
they were LA Raiders oh damn the classic
newer champs bro and there were champs
right so I couldn't imagine what it'd be
like to be up in Oakland like I was
gonna go just to see what it would be
like but then I just felt unsafe man it
was all black and then like a couple of
orange that's it for the Bengals it was
hard to do it like the dog seen it on TV
there was nothing really fast it was a
sea of black now one person knew who was
playing that card the kick car out of
the game and I was like what's all right
Carl okay he might cut it took Harley
game that's not cars lacking penis
behind me the whole time I gotta get
going oh yo man can I ask you a question
yes a lot of crops like how long have
you been doing the act that I saw you do
or the Act party like two years it's
turning up for the last two years they
have a different act on Netflix really
that's a different one our jokes right
stop talk about harm when I was a kid my
dad used to walk around the whole
neighborhood and collect furniture and
bring home and fix like MacGyver with
duct tape
one time he brought up television home I
said look that T we had 500 channels
when I got older today a half-hour in
his channels it was a knob from the oven
my favorite channel was 300 agrees wish
to watch the booster hazard on channel
broiled from all my mind one of my first
jobs I wrote and I say I just say that I
then it was a car accident you know it
no that's a car accident with another
Mexican it's worse you know we'll try to
automatic in each other a fantastic car
on it isn't [ __ ] you I start speaking
English first a mare your insurance
ticket is it think it is I fixed your
car right here
yeah what you like it yeah man I think
you I think you're making I could not
and it was it was a trap put me in a
show yeah yo you will you fabulous
fabulous yeah it was like brilliant -
thank you my brilliant but you're like
you look you look more like like you
look like check you yeah you know you
look like like when you look man let me
see how I was saying like a middle of
the country because I've been throughout
all of Mexico right and I've went to a
part where is like a tribe with like up
to my waist like that was the tall guy
they were I was like wow they're really
short like I'm Pablo yeah there sure
right there man like all of them I was
like hoho they're one haircut the mole
give me the mole Howard down to La Paz I
was like I said man like black folks
like you go different places they just
look different right you come out to
Oakland they look entirely different
than they do in New York City black
folks oh and look at that man you big as
hell but you look like what was that
movie when they said Majesties the
treasure of Sierra Madre yes Humphrey
Bogart like those those more [ __ ]
made you look like oh just we don't need
no stinking badges yeah didn't at the
end of the movie man nope these [ __ ]
Mexican the buzzer gets shot that
facility put on my heifers they got shot
after dude yeah always tough a movie bro
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] Mexican cowboy gets
shot ten times he looks over John Wayne
who got shot one time are you okay
seriously man is like whew that rough
the word marijuana thank you for making
it to so what's up fool
questions broadly more relationship
questions when you have your
relationship showed you that emerald
ring the one man they said Oh 420 I know
we gotta talk about that cuz you cuz
you're a little plump and girls like the
pump now electrical interest come in bro
it's like our Instagram is like I love
thick dudes and like now all the
pictures of the thick dudes and every
time somebody is is taking a selfie
that's naked is the tip dude they in
style I was like that's [ __ ] crazy -
a hashtag a little plump yes thick guys
getting all to play now oh yeah man
thank you for being here Thank You Man
thanks for being here bro
that a mission yep you want to promote
anything from the pot yeah no I'm just
gonna your weapons I'm gonna hook you up
we're gonna give you a vegan vegan food
share make sure you check it out check
out John Salley on Instagram the John
Salley on Twitter and Facebook you can
just check out the verified one and I'm
gonna be giving you these things for
thrive mark alright some some some
giveaways from beyond me and anything I
do can promote the lifestyle and it's a
trip because this is like literally when
I'm working on my life the only doing
I'm past and they said follow what
you're passionate about it's about
health and wellness so that's all I'm
doing
oh yeah that's it health and wellness
people and make sure you go be some wine
if you're in Whole Foods I want you to
ask for a wine called the vegan vine not
just vegan wine the vegan vine wine make
sure you go in I want a bottle with the
vegan vine why there's two things two
V's vegan vine wine that's more if they
say hey we don't have it - goddamn it
order it will order you some all the
cases help a brother out my kids in
private school you hear that people lots
of people do not buy any cheap cilantro
from anywhere I know this man you been
walking around out late trying to buy
cilantro and you couldn't find it Wow
I found that why one Lantern icon
because there were cilantro in Mexico
right they really grow it and there was
not a lady in the
workers go to the restroom so they were
[ __ ] peanut cilantro and they were
using as he lands him to take a poop on
it because they don't allow these
workers to use a restroom so these
farmers had to the restaurant a cilantro
that way it they stopped shipping
cilantro for a while man so they get a
bedroom really yeah so they improve
their working conditions oh that's why
you gotta buy stuff out of California
yeah we got five hundred and sixty
farmer markets here you know for less I
went to fulfill us with a Dominican girl
and she was dark and they didn't know
and these guys behind us was talking
[ __ ] talking in Spanish I know they were
talking [ __ ] and then she just looked
over rested just don't say that we
waiting on line I can't believe I'm in a
food for less I think this is pretty
slick like no this is like this is very
slick and then talking it turned around
and starts cursing them out in Spanish
and I was like why couldn't you just
know not even talking [ __ ] about you
being so tall maybe it's so small and I
probably probably ripped me either then
they said all that yeah Thank You Man
thing for being a guest on our podcast
man I think you I think you're hilarious
thank you John they arrived man amen
stay vegan Oh amber Egan oh yeah go
vegan in an artful upcoming shows next
week Denver at Comedy Works September
23rd to the 26 parlor live in Seattle
Washington October 8th through the 10th
row Julianne of either yes all right
Rodrigo so yes people have you been
asking Rodrigo will be a Seattle was all
over a lot of people in Seattle in over
her now a lot of friends Marcela and
Rodrigo we got that crazy ass full
fellow Phillips - I said shut up - DJ
Phillips washday Swanson never alive
live in West Nyack New York
October 22nd through 25th River Center
comedy club in San Antonio Texas
November 5th through the 8th man what'd
you think about fighters sadly bro what
so Alan Thicke hooking that up Alan from
vegan food share who hooked it up for us
thank you bro follow him on vegan food
share he's trying to get he's trying to
get to 500 thousand Paulo's
shut up to the wifey bro shoutout to
vegan DD nice cool also support all
things comedy everything on the page so
one thing about John Salley bro
he's a [ __ ] came in smooth you know
[ __ ] smooth roll like professional a
job some stand-up comedy shout-out to
Rory Hill although more boiled getting
ready for that 100 shout out to
everybody who listens to our podcast we
love you thank you for supporting our
podcast also man listen to the Joey COGO
Diaz call you yeah yeah yeah all right
podcast listen to Rodrigo and I we were
guests on the the Church of what's
happening and we promoted a web series
we were web series coming out in October
probably October 5th it's called um the
shop it's us the show it's a little web
series about me working in a medicinal
marijuana dispensary with Chris touring
and then Roger shows up dressed up like
Dilbert forward to the chorus the dating
champion elimidate' change your hearts
and I'll be they don't listen to our
show man oh I [ __ ] hope now dog [ __ ]
I know these chicks man this hopeful but
uh it's funny man a lot she's been
[ __ ] over a lot bro oh yeah they need
a new guy who's 9 another southerner
girl says hi all this [ __ ] - it
started yeah it's crazy
Cynthia and I hit me up on tumblr
everybody got a blog on your tumblr now
I tumble for you yeah bargaining [ __ ] so
that said nah fool I didn't like it fool
I mean use it man
yeah your snapchat yaffle okay
you're vegan vegan food sheer folly of
my snapchat I'm trying to see where I
was this weekend I was just at the
Raider game and went up the coast but to
Carmel Bros today did relaxing [ __ ]
relaxing bro you know like - relax bro
and not worry about stuff and I go on
Instagram and spend two hours there tag
your sponsor
I know tiger sponsor money man you gonna
be sneaking up you wanna watch flash on
Instagram you can't really search it
alight look up hashtag plums full house
I don't know if I told you this like in
the truck or something but dude man
[ __ ] [ __ ] would be spying on
your ass on [ __ ] Instagram this
[ __ ] called me the other day dog
you know mutual you know old friend of
ours like let's go get something to eat
I was like no I'm busy right now I'm
working and [ __ ] war I just seen you
like like thirty four photos on [ __ ]
it's I'm like what the [ __ ] full of my
dear come Mike I don't even care about
that I was like yeah but it just like
everything what's the matter - but I was
blown away that by that [ __ ] who do you
want to hang out bro they want you
nobody wants to give them information
bro
[ __ ] what information is funny what
information is there for you to give
when your whole life is out there yeah
well that's what I'm saying I don't your
page you know where you've been like you
see my likes my wife c-3po and has his
cool friend
c-3po who do you should promote yeah her
be hungary's real cool guy always always
there was a with a tight ass both hell
yeah you know and I said that a month
you know what I think that c-3po
murdered Mickey Thompson to take the
check over the promotion jobs he was one
of the suspects on the took over the
tennspeed he said when the suspect took
off on a ten-speed
and so yes because the killer should
cover the tennspeed
and when I made a friend I fell into
bikes yeah you
he will renovate or Nestle c3po they
found out that I wasn't super duper the
real promoter the real killer came out
yeah thank God
commemorative for Brian was made before
before anything before anything
it wasn't Mickey Thompson all the way
dude Riverside Pomona Mickey Thompson to
Arizona at the Anaheim Stadium making
the Annika Thomson wife and bickered are
they come murder that's the piece bigot
salsa now you're outta here man Pete
you